mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
start with a rectangle and construct one
of its diagonals
from the midpoint of the bottom side
construct two line segments that trisect
the top side
then consider the following triangle
if the rectangle has an area equal to 10
what is the area of this triangle
for convenience you can use these
letters to label the diagram
i was suggested this problem by email
and i was told that this problem was
given to 10 year old students it's quite
a challenging problem
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
i will present one way to solve this
problem
suppose the rectangle has a height equal
to h and a side length equal to s
then the bottom side is divided into two
lengths of s over 2 and the top side is
divided into 3 lengths of s over 3.
next consider the following two
triangles
they will be similar to each other and
therefore their lengths will be in the
same proportion
the smaller triangle has a side length
that's two-thirds that of the larger
triangle
therefore if we construct the height of
the larger triangle and say it's equal
to x
the height of the smaller triangle will
be equal to two-thirds of x
we then have x plus two-thirds x is
equal to h which means that x is equal
to three-fifths h
let's put this in this diagram right
here
and now let's consider two more similar
triangles
by the same logic their heights will be
in the same proportion as their sides
therefore if we say the height of the
bottom triangle is equal to y
the height of the top triangle will be
equal to four thirds y
we then have y plus four thirds y is
equal to h which means that y is equal
to three sevenths h
we substitute this in and now we can
solve the problem
first we will calculate the area of this
triangle
notice that we know its height and we
know its base so its area will be one
half the height times its base
we then will calculate the area of this
triangle and again we know its height
and we know its base so we calculate its
area and we want to subtract this area
the result will be the area of this
triangle
we do some algebra and we get that the
answer is equal to h times s times 3
over 70.
now we know one more fact the area of
the rectangle is equal to 10 and the
area of the rectangle is equal to h
times s
therefore we substitute in and we solve
that the area of this triangle is equal
to 3 over 7 and that's our answer
what's remarkable about the answer is it
doesn't depend on the particular
dimensions of the rectangle
as long as the rectangle has an area
equal to 10 the triangle has an area
equal to 3 over 7.
incredible
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube see
you next episode as we solve the world's
problems one video at a time